وصفات الامينه العامه المساعده للاتحاد
العامه التونسيه للشغل طيب وصف الازمه
الحاليه في تونس بالمعقده والمركبه واعتبر
حفيظنا المسار السياسيه الحالي في تونس
يمثل ارتداد وتراجعا عن مسار ال 25 من
يوليو بعد تفرد الرئيس قيس سعيد بالحكم
رئيس الجمهوريه وفعل الفصل الثاني هو
الضبابيه نتيجه المسار الانفرادي اللي
جسمه رئيس الجمهوريه بعد شهرين نزار
المرسوم بعد 117 واللي جمع فيه السلطات
الثلاث بين يديه
للجمهوريه على ان صياغه الدستور لتكون
تشاركيا حتى الحوار العاليه كان سوريا قلب
حتى على اقرب الناس له من جهابيده القانون
الدستوري الذبابيه الحال لما انفرد بنفسه
بصياغه قانون الانتخاب على قياسه الغفيه
الاجسام الوسيطه واللغ فيه الاحزان كل
المكونات السياسيه في البلاد
من جهه قال الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد ان
الافعال التي ياتيها البعض ترتقي الى
مرتبه التامر على امن الدوله الداخليه
والخارجيه
تصريحاته سعيد جاءت خلال لقائه وزيري
العدل والداخليه وبعد دعوات صريحه لقياده
سياسيه
بدعوه مؤسسات الدوله لعدم الانصياعه
لاوامره
وفي شاننا اخر قرار رئيس تونسي قيس سعيد
قالته وزيره التجاره وتنميه الصادرات ولي
صفاقس وجاء ذلك في بلاغ مقتضب لرئاسه
الجمهوريه دون ذكر الاسباب وقال المحافظ
الصف المقال فاخر
قال انه علم بقرار اقالته من خلال وسائل
الاعلام
في تصريحات لاذاعه المحليه انه فتح ملفات
خطيره اقلقت ما وصفه بما فيها صفاقس وفقه
تعبير
في نجم يكون السيد رئيس المعلومات غلطه
يمين قلت النفزه وتبعت برشا
واليوم بركه الكتب العام
يسال عليك موجوده
[موسيقى]